and there's a great new documentary film
that documents the 2019 team
20 years later as they fight for equal
pay
they fight to win a world cup on the
greatest stage
with so many people coming at them so
much adversity so many distractions
they're able to overcome and there's
this great new film
directed by andrea nix and we are
really excited to be able to have her
joining us here today alongside
sean fine who directed the film as well
but we're on with andrea right now
appreciate you taking the time talk to
me about your love of soccer
your connection to the game and where
this documentary
lfg sort of began its journey hey good
morning thanks for having me on
and um yeah that that actually oneonta
is not that far from where i grew up i'm
from rochester so
my love of the game played came from
related plan the sport i
started playing when i was little the
only sport i ever played
i just loved it and i'm that same age as
julie ferry more or less
so watching those women take the field
and do what they did and like watching
that game was kind of like
transformational i wasn't there in
person unfortunately but
but you know i just always followed it
so i thought i kind of knew a lot about
it but
when the lawsuit dropped we you know
looked up and and and so these are the
best women soccer players in the world
and this is what they're going through
why are they
i didn't really know too much about
anything to do with their equal pay
fight
and once we started sean my husband and
um fellow director on this once we
started looking into this it just felt
so incredible that look there's a lot
here that people don't know about
that we didn't even know about and um it
just felt like a
you know david versus goliath kinda
effort even though they are the best
what they do
um in the game for women and so it it
just felt like a natural thing this is
the right
moment i felt like people's ears are to
the ground in a different way about
equality
we felt like the rest the world should
know about it and they're also amazing
athletes an amazing personality so it
kind of has all the
boxes to check about likewise it's a
great story but
and it and it's really fun to film women
playing some badass soccer which is
really
what they're also all about so that was
just
all those things just drew me into this
to want to make this film
andrea nick's fine joins the show the
director of the new documentary
lfg story of the 2019 women's national
soccer team in their fight for equal pay
as they compete for a world cup
talk to me a little bit about what it's
like to hang out with megan rapino
you know she's you know it's kind of
like there's a song that's actually
played during the documentary where
we're sort of
giving a little background on her it's
it's like wizzy wiggy what you see is
what you get which is exactly
she she comes across exactly like you
see her
um she's very much like you know she's
kind of unflappable
she's really funny she's uh like
just a cool person she just has this
essence of cool and she's
fiercely intelligent and very articulate
so
that was also interesting to not just
see her on the field but then have her
walk onto
some pretty like meet the press and
rachel maddow and you know
really just intense interviewers who who
really like chicken like dish it
politically she conditioned on the field
she's
kind of uh like a renaissance woman and
that way and she's a lot of fun she's
funny and i think
um has a lot of respect from her
teammates um and she just
is able to articulate that's one of the
reasons we wanted her in the film she's
able to articulate
so quickly on behalf of the women but
also in some ways
not speak for them and and and she
speaks for herself but she sort of also
is the face of this movement for them
so she's great um and and i think she is
very important when we asked her to be
in the film she said look i'm in
but i'm not going to speak for everybody
else you have to ask people as
individuals
so that's what we started to do that's
what's so incredible about this team in
particular there's such a collection
of personalities and incredible life
journeys
they won the world cup in 2019. i
remember about a month or two later they
were going on a a tour of exhibition
games and they played
here in southern california at the rose
bowl where they of course you know team
won 20 years before
so i went to the friendly i was living
in pasadena at the time and that morning
in my local juice spot i saw sam muis i
saw jessica mcdonald and i
lost it like i got really emotional
i made everyone working in the juice bar
give them a standing ovation like
oh yeah it was i just i was so star
struck by them and
i'm glad you mentioned megan's thought
process of this can't be about me she
gets so much of the spotlight
talk to me about some of the other stars
on this team who audiences now are going
to watch in the olympics and we're
really kind of
making team usa their own yeah i mean i
think it's right like i think when you
do see jessica walk in a room
you do see sam walk in the room like you
notice right like first off they're just
like
they're they're powerful looking people
their powerful players
and the chemistry of of who told the
story for us
because we don't have narrators or
anything our style of documentary
filmmaking is really
we really want the characters to tell
their own story and so you really feel
like it it's there as it comes from them
and we wanted to be the right collective
idea so we had megan which is we talked
about already is that sort of a natural
choice is the face of sort of this fight
but we wanted to show the every player
the player that basically toils in
the professional league ranks with the
hope of one day maybe
just you know like if your dream comes
true to get pulled up to the nationals
and she's
a single mom she is an incredible like
fighter and
and so was so excited she but you know
this lawsuit dropped literally
just as she got on the national team so
that's kind of intense for her
to be part of swept into something like
this after all this time
so we also wanted to show the balance of
like hey they've been fighting this
lawsuit and you want we want to show how
much work that they
put into this this has been going on for
them for decades
even before they dropped it of their
prior team so
like becky sauerbraun is like an
incredible
you know just an incredible individual
she's a really quiet leader
um for the team like you have to kind of
know the team to understand how much
respect she has
amongst their ranks and she has been
working on the lawsuit cbas for years
um kelly o'hara same thing and
collectively they always bring on a new
player to sort of take you know hand the
baton to which is
kind of a great to make sure that they
understand what the team mentality is
about
the equal pay lawsuit about how it's
like a sisterhood
that they pass it on and so they want to
have a younger player understand
what it is to negotiate for their worst
across the table from the federation so
they want to make sure that
kind of baptize and bring into the fold
someone like samuel who's a rising star
and and that's kind of a really
interesting you know way that they
handle the
all the choices that they're making is
that they do it collectively they have
like they they have like seven players
who really work really hard on the
lawsuit and
um so i think what's really interesting
is you see like how articulate and how
well-versed they are in the law from
like becky and christian press and
kelly o'hara i mean i i think actually
someone like christian prescott
become a lawyer at the end of all this
ben lyons filling in for rich on the
rich eisen show joined right now by
andrea nicks fine
one half of the directing team behind
lfg the new documentary
celebrating the women's soccer team of
the united states in 2019 that
offer equal pay so what's the status of
the team right now with usa soccer as
they go over to japan they had a tough
start to kick off this
olympics uh losing which is not
something they normally do
to sweden three nothing the other day
what's the status of the team
right now in terms of their their
working relationship with their employer
well you know i think like anything with
a lawsuit you can settle at any time
right so what happened at the end is
that the the judge
sort of split the lawsuit in half and
they settled on the working conditions
but the equal pay lawsuit
side of things continues and they're
still fighting it an appeals process
and and according to them they're going
to go to the very end of where it takes
um they believe in it so and that
they you know do could they sit down at
the table at any time yeah
they can and but you know history says
that's complicated for both sides
and i think both sides would really love
to come to some kind of conclusion about
it i think we would love to have
been able to show that in the film
because i think it shows possibility and
all friends not just in the soccer world
of how you kind of compromise and get
where you're going
but still like you know these women want
to continue this until the very end
and i i believe in them i think you can
see through the film that
they kind of give jet fuel to this whole
idea for a lot of women across the world
not just female athletes but women
all over um so they carry that
fight on their back so i think it's hard
i think it's hard it's like going to
work every day
in an active lawsuit with your boss but
you're working right next to them and
you need their support for you as a
player right but so they
they have and and the federation needs
the the player so
as they say that we're the only game in
town for each other
so i you know i hope i hope it ends well
for both of them
honestly the new film is lfg all about
the women's soccer team but you worked
over the years with
athletes like lindsay vaughn and i'm
just curious as a filmmaker and a sports
fan when you watch
games when you watch the olympics are
you looking for stories to tell
what is it that draws you as a filmmaker
to the world of sports
you know it's interesting i think sports
is tricky because you know we do lots of
other stories besides sports so
the thing is it's got to be a great
story and all great stories start with
great characters so that's really where
you start you start
with someone who is in the midst of
something transformational has the
ability to
come across emotionally and kind of
bring you into their journey
and that's the exact same case we have
with these women on this story
so i think you you're always looking for
somebody whose journey is going to take
you inside of something
amazing and that they're able to sort of
share
their perspective and have it be
relatable to someone ex like
circumstances that let's say you know
when you watch the film you don't know
anything about soccer
or you don't know anything about the law
we welcome you in
because i think as an audience you'll
come out better verse but really feel
like emotionally moved like i think
cinema is an emotional
as an emotional ride ultimately so
that's really what we look for and
that's one of the reasons we felt like
these women were the perfect
you know subjects to go through this
journey with it's it's a great
documentary it's a great way to honor
what these women have to overcome in
order to just fulfill their dreams as
professional soccer players
and i was really inspired by it as i was
by the 99 team way back when so i
appreciate you taking some time
andrea besso no we appreciate it thanks
so much i enjoyed speaking with you
the film is lfg available now i think
about the women's soccer team
one they're they're the best team we
have in the united states in any sport
they're the most dominant
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here